donc
[Musique]
nous nous sommes énormément amusés sur le
premier film
[Musique]
bon bon excellent
il y avait une énergie sur le plateau que c'était
la première fois que vous voyiez quelque chose
comme ça
j'étais enthousiasmé par tout ce que ça
pouvait être
quand j'ai vu le dinosaure dans la bande-annonce
et que j'ai vu les ondulations sur l'eau,
j'étais comme oh mon Dieu, cela a vraiment défini ma
génération ce film
j'ai pleuré la première fois que j'ai vu des dinosaures
tout à coup ce qui n'avait jamais semblé
réel
auparavant était totalement réel et  j'ai réalisé à
ce moment que le cinéma avait changé pour toujours la
domination du monde jurassique est l'
aboutissement de la franchise il
conclut une histoire que stephen spielberg a
commencé à raconter en 1993
lorsque nous sommes sortis du monde jurassique je savais que
ça allait être vraiment spécial
je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer  nous serions ici à
travailler aux côtés de sam neil et jeff
goldblum et laura dern c'est assez
fantastique
c'est tellement amusant c'est tout ce que nous
aurions pu espérer et plus je
pensais que c'était une idée fantastique  pour réunir
ces deux mondes,
cela a été un grand privilège d'être le
gardien de quelque chose comme ça nos
personnages hérités nos personnages du monde jurassique
sont de retour
nos histoires se croisent c'est la
convergence des deux franchises dont
nous avons besoin pour réparer une terrible erreur et
surtout continuer  une véritable
aventure effrayante comme l'enfer honnête envers Dieu
c'est ce à quoi tout a
conduit je pourrais utiliser votre expertise vous venez
ou ce que
[Musique]
retient les gars
pourquoi
doivent-ils toujours aller plus gros
ne bougez pas
[Musique]
vous